[Music]
i started thinking about this film
originally in 2012
after a story that i had read about a
woman
named savita jalapenova who died in
ireland
after being denied a life-saving
abortion and i
became really obsessed with reading
about what is insensitively coined
abortion tourism
these long you know distressing
journeys that people take all over the
world
to access very essential
abortion care and i think i'm
really compelled to tell stories
about kind of painful journeys that
people
go through that you haven't seen on
screen
i found an article about new york that
was all about how new york is the
abortion capital
of the united states and it's a place
where you can get
the care that you need and
i i said it in pennsylvania because
pennsylvania is one of 37 states that
has parental consent laws that require
teenagers to ask their parents or go
see a judge if they need an abortion
i was exploring the film through the
point of view of
a teenager i felt like it was realistic
that she could take this trip
from pennsylvania to new york i was just
going about my everyday life working in
a grocery store and
playing a band and living with like four
roommates
and um just one day i get an email
you know asking me to try out for this
part and it was
just super bizarre and um came as a
total surprise to me
and at first i immediately declined
immediately it was just thought to
myself i'm not an actor
and um i just thought it was something i
wasn't capable of
and it was also like a terrifying
opportunity because
of the fact that it was something so new
and so big i chatted with scott eliza's
partner a bit
and you know he told me like well you're
a performer and you know
you can totally do it and um he
convinced me to you know like
skype with eliza and i talked with her
and i found her really easy to get along
with
and i liked her ideas and um
and then i read the script and you know
i was then i became further invested
into the story
i really loved just like the just like
how grounded all the characters felt
and how real it felt and like i just had
a feeling that it was going to be a very
powerful story
and that it was just going to be the
type of
project that would be really humbling to
work on
i met with kelly chapman who worked at
choices clinic
in queens and together
we began to try and figure out like a
way to marry what she does as a social
worker
how she behaves in the office
with the style of the script she was a
real
sounding board for me while i was
writing the scripts
i kept on calling her and asking her
questions and while i was writing the
script
i began to sort of hear her voice and
the character on the page
and i knew that it was important to cast
her in the end
um because i had essentially
accidentally like
written the role for her and i felt that
it would
create um a really safe space for
sydney a first time actor to perform the
scene
there's something about this like
vulnerable first-time actor
being you know in the care of a real
social worker
that allowed for a certain level
of emotional vulnerability i
wanted the pivotal scene of the film and
never rarely
sometimes always to be truly
authentic it was important to me
to consult with planned parenthood and
other clinics while writing the script
and i sat with a lot of social workers
and began to try and understand
as a writer what their job is and
how they would engage with somebody who
was a minor
traveling from out of state they took me
through the process
the questionnaire form and that's where
i found the intimate partner violence
section
in which a social worker would try and
assess whether or not
the person who was in their office was
safe or not
i was working at an abortion clinic in
queens when eliza was doing
research she wanted specifically
to talk about not just my experience
as a counselor an abortion counselor but
specifically you know wanted to hear
some stories
about women who women and girls who had
traveled
and of course there were a lot of
stories it was a really important part
of the story for me
because autumn as a character is
traveling through
such an unsafe landscape
you know there's no place in her world
that's completely safe
until she arrives in the office of the
social worker
hi autumn kelly i'm your counselor how
are you doing
okay
i want to spend a few minutes talking
with you about your relationships okay
because they can affect your health did
you know that
no all right so i'm going to ask you
some questions
they can be really personal and all you
have to do is answer either never
rarely sometimes or always it's kind of
like multiple choice but it's not a test
okay okay in the past year
your partner has refused to wear a
condom
never rarely sometimes
always
sometimes okay and your partner messes
with your birth control or tries to get
you pregnant when you don't want to be
never rarely
sometimes always
never okay your partner's threatened or
frightened you
never rarely
sometimes always
why are you asking me this i want to
make sure that you're safe
your partner's threatened or frightened
you
never rarely
sometimes always
oh rarely okay
your partner has hit you slapped you or
physically hurt you
never rarely
sometimes always
has your partner ever hit you slapped
you or physically hurt you
is someone hurting you
it's okay
it's just a couple more questions all
right
your partners made you have sex when you
didn't want to
never rarely
sometimes always
it's okay
i want to make sure you're safe and i
want to help you if i can
i have just one more question for you
okay autumn
has anyone forced you into a sexual act
ever in your lifetime yes or no
uh yeah okay
do you wanna tell me about it no no it's
okay
i'm gonna give you my number and you can
call me
we don't have to talk about it today but
you can call me if you need to talk or
if you need some help okay
do you have any questions for me um
is it the procedure is it gonna be
painful
it's gonna be a little uncomfortable
have you ever had a gyn exam before
no okay it's going to be in an
operating room there's going to be a
doctor there's going to be a nurse
there's going to be a medical assistant
i can be there with you if you want me
to be
would you like me to go with you sure
okay
okay so it's kind of like having a gyn
exam today
they're going to put a speculum in the
vagina
they're going to put laminaria into the
cervix and that's what's going to help
the cervix open overnight
all right so it's going to feel
uncomfortable kind of like pressure kind
of like you have to pee but it shouldn't
hurt
okay okay if you have any really bad
pain tonight you have to call us
okay then when you come back tomorrow
for the second part of the procedure for
that part you're gonna be asleep
okay and i can be with you then too i'm
gonna like go under
okay just for about 10 minutes it's
pretty quick all right
and then when you wake up you'll be in
the recovery room you're gonna be all
done
and you could go home okay all right
are you ready i think so
okay when it came to preparing for this
scene
i spent a lot of time reflecting
on my own memories and experiences
as a young woman which can be difficult
and sometimes rather hard to think about
and
when i thought about this scene i
thought you know this is somebody who's
finally making herself vulnerable
and feel safe enough to do so and you
know so tapping into my own
places and experiences and getting into
that headspace
was important and working with
the social worker who was a real social
worker made me feel comfortable enough
to
dive into that place and to really
let my own experiences inform the scene
basically i did a counseling session i
did a counseling session like i've done
i think i've seen like somewhere in the
neighborhood of like 15
to 20 000 women in like the decade that
i was
that i was doing abortion counseling so
i've had this conversation
many many many times so i just had to
have the conversation i just had to put
myself in that headspace and
do what i do there was
the piece of the script
where she didn't want me to go off
script
at all um and that's
you know specifically when we get to the
likert scale
there were specific responses that she
wanted me
to give the day that we shot the scene
i made sure that sydney had a
space to sit away from the commotion
of the production a quiet office
and she sat in there for a long time and
she read the scene
several times and i remember right
before we shot i came
in and i told her i said don't worry
about
the character's medical history you can
just
answer as yourself because the beginning
of the scene
just begins with a lot of medical
information medical history
and there was something about sydney
starting from a very personal place
speaking about her own life her own
history
that allowed for her to dig much deeper
in the more sort of emotional and
heightened
section of the scene i chose to shoot
the scene
very simply you know i wanted the camera
to be very still
in front of her and static and
i wanted it almost to be
like a mirror for the character and i
wanted
it to feel a little like an
interrogation and it was important for
me that the audience
sit through the entire scene like in a
long take
and for it to play out in a durational
sense
because i wanted them to experience what
it's like to really sit in one of those
offices
and particularly i wanted to bring a
male audience into such an intimate
experience
to film the scene for me it was
really powerful it felt
[Music]
amazing to be able to harness my own
experiences and emotions
from maybe my past or even just what i
was dealing with in the present
and you know considering what autumn had
gone through
and harnessing all that to create a
moment
that so many people have connected with
and um
were moved by and i remember i believe i
said that i felt
cathartic afterwards and it felt
just like it just felt like so much
energy had left my body
and i felt um just so
alive eliza said you know i just
as we're going through the casting
process i just keep hearing your voice
in my head
and i would really love for you to do it
and my my initial reaction was like
oh my god i don't know how to do this
like are there gonna be like cue cards
or something like i have
no idea about how any of this works
but she said no i i just want you to
i want you to be yourself i want you to
do
what you've done a million times before
and just have the conversation that
you've had so many times before so
she wasn't asking me to be anyone other
than who i
am so i completely
trusted her i completely trusted eliza
um you know i don't know that i would
have
said yes and been involved in that
capacity
with just anyone but i i knew i knew
from
my you know previous conversations and
interactions with her that
this was gonna be a project that i would
be
very happy to have my my name and my
professional reputation attached to um
i remember in the moment shooting that
scene that
it felt very powerful to me personally
just the experience of doing it shooting
it was
it was intense you know i had hopes that
other people would think the same
and you know seeing now that they have
it's um
really validating and it's uh it feels
really good
i wanted the audience to understand
the depth of her trauma
and how much she is how much pain she's
carrying around
with her and how the situation of having
to travel
and to do it all on her own like how
much
trauma that can add for a real person
in this country who's navigating similar
[Music]
situations